[Music]
hi river babes
I'm your host Liana Galera and this is
your Sweetwater secrets after-show for
episode 406 chapter 63 hereditary now
unlike episode 405 there are a few
unexpected twists this week like the
fact that jugheads teacher doge head
first out of a window and two people we
despise are apparently dating but
overall i'm still not sure why our
characters are being placed in these
situations or what is actually happening
now fYI this isn't shade it's just
candid confusion now to help bring us
some joy and sanity I have an exclusive
interview with Camila Mendes and KJ app'
talking all about VAR Chi plus I've got
some of your best kisses and kisses so
get excited for that because I know I
was when I read them but first let's
recap what on earth is going on this
week with the blue and gold breakdown
okay I'm gonna recap this by couples to
make things move a little faster
so first up Betty and Jughead were
supporting each other while they each
embarked on their own investigative
missions this week Jughead was trying to
prove that his grandfather wrote the
first Baxter boys books and then thanks
to an old Riverdale high literary
magazine he was able to connect the dots
and unfortunately then he asked his
professor to help him spread the truth
at Stonewall and mr. what's-his-name
decided to dive headfirst out of a
window instead and literally no one
blinked an eye I hate the school
meanwhile Betty it was determined to
prove that Charles was a serial killer
so she visited chick in jail to get
answers and then broke out her polygraph
skills to challenge Charles because sure
now both Charles and chick claimed that
the other killed someone but then
Charles finally got on Betty's good side
by helping FP get rid of a body and then
Chicken Charles are a couple because we
can't have nice things I don't I don't
know
as for Shoni goodness gracious buckle up
that damn Julian doll was still haunting
thistle house and according to Cheryl it
broke free from its salt circle and
caused one of the twin babies to choke
on a ping pong ball
Cheryl's aunt and uncle we've never
heard of showed up and tried to get her
to sell thistle house she said no and
then decided to drown the doll zhu
banished the spirit honestly I could not
make this up if I try it but by the end
of the hour
Cheryl's uncle snuck into the chapel and
found Jason's dead body oh and get this
he then attacked Cheryl called her all
sorts of nasty things and then Tony
being the knees and girlfriend that she
is hit him over the head and now
apparently they're hiding yet another
body in thistle house what up Archie and
Veronica you asked
well at first Veronica tried to keep
Hiram and random sister ho mosa out of
her life but hey this is Riverdale that
lasted a total of two seconds so Hiram's
deduced his way back into Hermione's
life move back into the Pembroke along
with Hermosa and now Veronica has a
mother who betrayed her a sister who's
hugging the spotlight and a rub loving
father who will not leave us alone
meanwhile I cannot believe we're only on
Episode four oh six because this Dodger
reverse archie storyline is already
feeling endless you know the drill
Dodger is using the kids in Riverdale to
do bad things and Archie is still
pretending to be a superhero
so he gets Veronica's helped to put
arcade games in the Ellroy out to
distract the kids but then Dodger got
pissed realize that Archie is the one in
the black hood mask and then rained
bullets on Archie's house Archie asked
for Hiram's help and then Dodger was
found near dead inside of a rug and okay
yeah now here's an interview with KJ a
blonde Camilla Mendez talking about poor
Chi in season four I loved that about
season one so I'm really happy we're
going back to that wholesome area and
don't get me wrong it's just as absurd
as it's ever been but we're definitely
kind of focusing more on high school and
that feels really nice to go back to
what do you think Archie I think I'm
really amped about the fact that the
season
is following that season one trajectory
because it means more call for and it's
a little bit more grounded I think than
the other season so I'm excited to dive
deeper into something more grounded and
something that means something to me as
well as is my character he wants to do
something to help Riverdale I think
Riverdale was kind of on a downward
slope and I think he sees how Royale is
a way to help people out and maybe turn
it into a community center for people
who are struggling what's this now where
she can't obviously we know that Archie
storyline this year is gonna be all
about paying homage to his late father
how is Veronica gonna really help him
with that
at the end of season two we see what
happens to Freddy to get shot and then
in season three we pick up and
Veronica's kind of struggling to be that
supportive girlfriend cuz she's never
really been in a relationship like that
before and I think now I think Veronica
finally has a chance to kind of be there
and support him and she's kind of
prepared for it and is stepping up to
that role so I think that's a pretty
pretty sweet storyline I think that's
our cue to archiekins
oh we're gonna get a lot of happy party
scenes I think so far at least Bart
she's going really strong and they have
a lot of cute cuddly beautiful romantic
scenes so it's great what's that like
for you and KJ to snap into that mode
it's funny honestly like we make it as
grotesque and humorous as possible
anything we can do to gross each other
out you're kidding season full of
they're pretty solid yeah I would say
more solid than ever
obviously Archie going through a pretty
rough moment in his life of this guy
passing I think she's going through some
stuff of her own so I think yeah she
could definitely you know there for each
other mm-hmm will we get any happy
moments between Virgie of course really
I feel like they do consistently bring
us the happiest of the moments of all
the couples on the show there's some
have you guys yeah anything you can
cheese for us any date teas no dates but
[Music]
there is
I love you Ronnie same archiekins same
I love how KJ just like awkwardly
trailed off in the cutest way possible
and on the topic of romantic moments
let's take a look at the most romantic
moments of the week in seven seconds in
heaven now unlike last week this episode
actually had a couple sweet moments
including the fact that Jughead called
Betty his anchor all and then they had
this really sweet smooch and I adored
that we had some really sweet barchi
moments in the El Royale and then this
happened
who else felt really really
uncomfortable during the Hyrum Hermione
hookup raise your hands anyone just me
okay
well I'm glad we can all agree on there
now let's see if you all agreed with me
about this week's episode as we take a
look at your kisses and kisses mm-hmm
now you guys are already sending in so
many amazing comments right now so I see
you we're coming to you but I also
called out on Twitter and our first
tweet comes from the Ville of Archie and
they said kisses to Betty and Jughead
being sweet and supportive
kisses also to Veronica for being so
strong with her crazy family sis you
need to talk it out hisses to the whole
Julian storyline I'm kind of creeped out
I never thought Drowned demon doll would
be something I would ever hear yeah
let's talk about Sheryl for a minute
shall we now I'm sending hisses to the
fact that they've completely altered
Cheryl's vernacular it was funny when
she's through in a few like thou and
Hulse but this has gotten out of control
especially when you add in the fact that
tony has had like a total of five lines
all season now I also want to send extra
hisses to the new blossom family members
stop giving us random family members in
season four but on a more serious note
hisses to the awful and horribly
insensitive way that the uncles spoke to
Sheryl into the physical violence
against her we all know that Sheryl has
been through a lot and the topic of her
mental health is something that we've
been mentioning a lot lately but this is
just wow
I really feel badly for everything that
this character is going through and I
just think it could be handled better
yeah yeah let's take a look at what you
guys are having to say right now um this
friend's fan forever says isn't it weird
that Betty and Jughead who are a couple
live together with their parents who
also happen to be a couple oh and the
fact that they share a half-brother I'd
be weirded out if it was me I completely
agree I would be rooted out too but in
terms of Riverdale level of crazy that's
pretty minor so we're just gonna let
them all live in the Jones Cooper house
because sure just sure Frank narf says
hisses - all these storylines that
aren't connecting with each other I
completely agree this is something that
I heart on the lot after last week's
episode and it happened again it's great
they were getting more core four but
they're very rarely crossing each
other's paths they're also not in school
except for Jughead and apparently that's
not a good school to be in because
people are literally diving to leave it
okay Catina
Val Cova said when are they going to
leave Cheryl alone I mean how much more
can a teenage girl take
I completely agree it is a lot and I
feel like I understand that they're
having a therapy episode that's coming
up soon but if they think that that's
just gonna be a magic wand that's gonna
suddenly reset everything and
everything's gonna be just fine
I don't think that's gonna happen yeah
not quite um echo wall says like
seriously Jughead says things like are
you warming up to our half-brother now
like he's asking about the weather
once again it's Riverdale so the fact
that he shares a half-brother with his
girlfriend it's just Tuesday yeah okay
let's have another Queen tweet tweet
quick tweet that's what I was going for
from bednar hope said kisses dude
Jughead for calling Betty his anchor and
kisses to all the ships this episode
mr. Charles for being Shady why can't he
be normal and hisses - hi room for just
being Hiram yes I agree Hiram was
annoying this week but I never thought
I'd say this but kisses to Hiram for
saying such one
things about Fred Andrews and for
turning Archie down and refusing to put
a hit on Dodger now I'm not saying that
Hiram didn't put a hit on Dodger but it
was nice to see him remind Archie to be
better and I can't imagine that f-that
Fred Andrews would want Archie to be
going down the path that he's on right
now I understand that he has good
intentions but once again this is not
what he wanted and we all know that okay
we have le Lawrence said kiss sister
Alice for being the most adorable baby
ever well she's a grown woman but yes I
know what you mean Ruth is not hi good
for you Ruth says hisses - still no F P
Alice kiss ya they live together it's
honestly it's is it like a joke at this
point are they gonna just give us a kiss
most epic F P Ellis kiss ever are they
together are they not and they're just
friends who live together I'm not quite
sure anymore of it yes I would like to
see that kiss on Meghan violet says girl
your hair is so cool thanks Megan
shout-out to Jessica Davis my makeup
artist who did my hair and my makeup
this week isn't it cool to have that now
guys didn't happen first two seasons
finally got hair and makeup whatup
Riverdale okay Megan violet said that
and then Paulina says kisses to your
outfit thanks guys this is cool
so this was a really dramatic episode of
Riverdale so I picked my most dramatic
shirt and it looks kind of insane but I
think it goes I feel like it's a cross
between something that Veronica and
something Cheryl would wear drop okay
miss friends fans forever says sometimes
I think Archie has a brain tumor or some
other head injury that would explain all
of his reckless behavior okay that's a
little extreme Archie I think is just a
very reckless person but the one thing
that kept standing out to me is he keeps
saying that there's all these kids that
Dodgers recruiting and he's just telling
people's like they're just kids
they're just kids like you're just a kid
you're supposed to be like 17 or 18 dude
you're just a kid it would make a lot
more sense if these kids and by kids I
mean these teens on the show we're
actually their real age like mid-20s
because then all the things that they're
going through right now I'd be like
that's still
but I believe it more yeah we have
another tweet and that's gonna be from
at bug head lover 12 and he said his
sister Hyrum and Hermione getting back
together like what the actual hell
number one that scene was gross I agree
number two she tried to kill you two
times and number three he tried to kill
you once lord help these two yeah I am
really sounds it sounds so weird to say
I'm disappointed in Hermione but I'm so
disappointed in Hermione poor Veronica
she is she still Veronica Luna who knows
but she needs to get the hell out of
that house because she just keeps having
people who are backstabbing her like I'm
predicting it now and I have no idea
what's happening in this next season but
I'm sure that at one point like she and
her sister gonna team up and they
actually become good friends and that
we're all gonna end up loving Hermosa
but no not me not me okay Andrew Valdez
says it's got great horror vibes I'm
digging that yeah it does I don't know
if this is horror anymore I don't know
it's just people are just dying or
jumping out of windows or showing up
almost dead in rugs I feel like everyone
or or uncovering dead bodies hey there
were dead bodies in every story line
this week way to go Riverdale every
characters couple had to deal with a
dead body
cute Anna said kisses to bug head
supporting each other we love a healthy
relationship yes honestly at this point
bug head I
Betty supporting Jughead really well
considering he's supposed to be where is
this school he said in the episode like
I'm gonna catch the next train and come
see you but then it seems like they can
just spontaneously meet up where is he
living at home is he not do I care I
think so okay ranae underscore my life
says kisses to Tony
saving Cheryl yes let's talk about Tony
saving Cheryl once again Tony to the
rescue God loved Tony for being there
for Cheryl I will say I would love to
have Tony have her own storyline apart
from Cheryl that's not to say that I
don't love Shoni
you guys know right or die but I'm
getting really
exasperated just seen Tony in the
background of scenes Cheryl's in when
Cheryl's going off on her big like thou
art thou monologues and Tony's just in
the back when babe oh babe I love you
babe I support you babe and she's an
amazing girlfriend and we should really
be commending her for this but Oh
poor Tony girlfriend of the year am i
right yeah okay Julia men Menendez says
barchi and just a heart yeah yeah
Georgia slight says where are the
football and cheerleading like promised
yeah I don't know
and also Roberto aguirre-sacasa told me
at Comic Con that we were gonna be
getting more musical moments because
Archie was gonna be starting the band
the Archies which is I just guess that's
just what it's called cuz it was that in
the comics but alright he was gonna be
starting the band called the Archie's
but I can't imagine when he's gonna do
that unless they're gonna perform at the
El Royale
what is the Elroy out now is it a gym is
it a community center is it just an
arcade and why are all the kids in
Riverdale so obsessed with arcades games
these are the questions guys these are
the questions okay Ellie Lauren says
that was the worst she's referring to
the hiram hookup scene it felt so creepy
I don't even know it felt wrong and then
Hermione liked it and it went on for way
too long it already feels weird
sometimes when we're watching the kids
hookup so don't give us the parents I
don't know nobody's actually shipping
Hyrum and Hermione that was FP and Alice
we'd be like hell yeah but nobody
actually cares about Hermione and Hyrum
we have another tweet and that's from at
river fan 2019 and they said kisses to
Archie for saving his mom from the
Dodger attack yes
it says do Charles for working with
chick hisses to whatever reason mr.
chipping jumped through a window and no
students except jugg were helping him
his sister who mosa for replacing
Veronica's self-portrait with her own
lots of hisses there and I respect it
we'll bounce it out with a kiss from
Andrew over nada Gomez and said kiss mr.
Ronnie for supporting Archie through his
crazy vigilante nonsense I don't even
think she knows that he's
doing this maybe she does I'm not quite
sure but as far as let's talk about
chicken Charles we've been through this
and and now they're still hooking up I'm
so upset it was like an earthquake on my
set um
okay here we make Emily Henze says in
the spring semester flash forward from
the last episode when FP walked into the
room to arrest Betty and her friends for
the murder of his son
I think they murdered Charles not jug
within my wood jugs body beyond the
autopsy table also once again I'm seeing
more and more theories that these
flash-forwards are just scenes from the
book that jugheads writing so like maybe
they're not actually happening it's just
he's writing a book inspired on these
characters and that's what we're
actually seeing that's what I'm gonna go
with right now that as far as Charles
goes I don't care anymore that he's with
chick and I night cuz I feel like and
chick keeps popping up and I'm not quite
sure it's happening and like if they
want to be in love go be in love but at
the same time like yeah let's just look
at yeah let's just look at this because
this just makes no sense and then
they're like
I don't know anymore I don't know and I
don't mean to be it like I saw in the
comments last week you guys were saying
like Lee Anne so over this and and tired
of the show and I feel badly because we
all adore this show and that's why we
started Sweetwater in the first place
was to have a place where the fans could
talk and we keep it positive but there's
only so much positivity we can have when
things don't make any sense if things
were making sense I'd be like okay
that's weird not my choice but I don't
write the show and once again I think
the writers are doing an incredible job
it's just it's not okay just a couple
more questions Tay Reed says kisses to
Jughead for trying to figure out more
about his grandpa he definitely needs
something in his life to be consistent
this is true but I'm pretty sure his
Grandpa's supposed to be dead but it's
Riverdale he'll come back alive he'll
come back no worries about that bomb
Excel said hisses to that damn Julian
doll Sherrill just burned the thing
already please yes and also I thought I
saw a lot of comments on Twitter saying
how upsetting they thought it was that
Cheryl was trying to drown the doll
considering Cheryl herself tried to
commit suicide at the end of season one
by drowning and that's something that
still has not been addressed and really
talked about and so we should get on
that okay lastly Olivia tube says can we
talk about how many people live in the
Jones Cooper house and how many bedrooms
are also in there I swear they're just
repurposing Betty's bedroom for every
situation
it's jugheads room it's Betty's room
it's jellybeans room it's everybody's
room and now we're done let's be done I
am having fun with you guys I don't want
you to think that I'm not this is great
I'm just really overwhelmed this is just
a lot we're only in episode six figure
we go all right thank you all so much
for watching be sure to join us next
week for the Sweetwater secrets after
shell for episode 407 chapter 64 the ice
storm because I'll be bringing you a
very special interview with the core for
talking about how much longer they think
Riverdale is going to last and you will
not want to miss their answers but for
now please give this video a like hit
subscribe so you never miss an episode
and then head on down to the comments or
tweet me with all of your thoughts are
you act out by Chicken Charles who are
you most mad
hyrum Hermione or Hermosa and do you
think Cheryl's storyline can be saved
tell me everything and I'll see you soon
River babes
[Music]
you